it is my honor and privilege to
introduce the next speaker in the CC
a-series robert d kaplan is chief
geopolitical analyst for Stratford a
private global intelligence firm and a
non-resident fellow at the Center for a
new American security mr. Kaplan served
as a member of the Pentagon's defense
policy board under secretary of state
the Secretary of Defense Robert Gates
and as the class of 1960 distinguished
visiting professor in national security
at the United States Naval Academy
Annapolis a consultant to the US Army's
Special Forces Regiment in the US Air
Force and the Marines he is a foreign
correspondent for the Atlantic and his
essays have been featured in the New
York Times The Washington Post the
Financial Times and The Wall Street
Journal he is the author of several
books including Balkan ghosts a journey
through history warrior politics and
most recently The Revenge of geography
what the map tells us about coming
conflicts in the battle against fate
please join me in welcoming robert d
kaplan
good afternoon everyone it's it's really
a great privilege to be back at
Hillsdale I spoke here 25 years ago in
the spring of 1988 and my subject then
was the Ethiopian famine where I had
just completed a book about and
throughout the 80s I covered the wars in
Ethiopia Iran Iraq Afghanistan and and
so forth and since then I've been doing
just more of the same just finding
different places of the world to write
about and let let me just say that I'm
gonna be talking about a subject today
that's a bit tender it it will be a bit
hard to listen to in certain ways
because what Hillsdale is about and what
many of you about are about is all the
things that human beings can accomplish
all a you know overcoming adversity
putting your mind to something and
accomplishing it about the power of
human agency as the intellectuals call
it and what I'm gonna be talking about
is different it's gonna be about
constraints the limitations that that we
all labor under let me put it this way
if you read the editorial page of The
Wall Street Journal and then turn to the
editorial page of the New York Times or
the editor or read the National Review
and then read the nation you would think
oh this is different some are liberal
some are conservative in a sense they're
all the same because what it's all about
is the power of ideas the power of what
Washington can accomplish if only it
would do this and that and the other
things the elite and and and and all of
these journals of opinion and op-ed
pages deal with
they they're written by and they deal
with an elite and what an elite molders
of public opinion fly back and forth
across the earth and business class and
they look down from 30,000 feet and they
think they can engineer reality from
above and that's all true to an extent
human beings can accomplish many things
a lot of the ideas you read about in
your journal your favorite journals are
very coherent ones but what I'm here to
talk about is the other 50% of reality
the constraints the limitations and
principle among those constraints is
geography and by geography I do not just
mean the map in front of us
I mean geography in the 19th century
sense of the word in the sense of not
just mountains and rivers and plains and
coastlines I mean also Natural Resources
population pathways of trade the
environment the environment and a
strategic sense not in an aesthetic a
spotted owl sense let's save the spotted
owl I mean the environment in terms of
what are the underground sources of
fresh water for a country like China or
Yemen and are they running out of such
sources that's what I mean when I talk
about the environment and let me let me
go around the world and give you a sense
of this this is not about how human
beings are just slaves to fate how
they're prone to force is so large that
there's little that they could do to
overcome them this is just a way to look
more to see a more powerful version of
the earth and to give you another an
added layer of perspective to that goes
in addition to all the layers
that you already do have I'm gonna start
with the Middle East and I'm gonna go
around the world in the next half hour
the Arab Spring the so-called Arab
Spring which was really not about
democracy it was instead a crisis in
central authority and when that central
authority imploded there was often
nothing - nothing to replace it the Arab
Spring began in Tunisia why did it begin
in Tunisia if you look at the map of the
Mediterranean and the Middle East you
will see that no Arab country was closer
to Europe than Tunisia it's only 7 hours
by slow car ferry from Tunis to Trapani
in western Sicily it's a car ferry I've
taken several times in my life
throughout medieval and early modern
history the links between what is today
Italy and what is today's Tunisia were
immense they were extraordinary
interwoven no Arab country was as
interwoven with European culture as the
coast of Tunisia if you look at a road
map of Tunisia you'll find that most of
the roads were built by the Romans
today's roads and they were enhanced by
the Byzantines and the Vandals and the
Turks and and and and others Tunisia was
was not just an empty place on a map it
was an age-old cluster of civilization
that was an extension of Europe in its
in the northern third of the country so
the Arab Spring began in the most
Europeanized part of the Arab world this
was no accident it was a part of the
Arab world that because it was so
Europeanized it had a very
well-developed statement al
identity was not just about Islam
identity was about being a Tunisian
which had a state had a Motor Vehicles
Bureau had an Agricultural Extension
Service it had institutions and
bureaucracies and electricity grids and
stoplights and garbage service that
actually worked the very mundane things
that we take for granted often do not
exist in many parts of the developing
world but they existed in Tunisia and
yet when the Romans finally conquered
Carthage because what is Tunisia but
age-old greater Carthage when the Romans
finally conquered Carthage they dug a
demarcation ditch in 202 BC called in
Latin a fossa regia and this demarcation
dish delineating civilized territory
from uncivilized territory and the
demarcation ditch went several hundred
miles south from the Mediterranean into
the desert and then east back to the
Mediterranean because Tunisia has both
an eastern coastline and a northern
coastline on the Mediterranean and
everywhere inside of that ditch between
the Mediterranean and that ditch was
where the roads were built was where a
state was developed in antiquity and
everywhere outside of that ditch was
left to disuse look and and if you look
at Tunisia's development map at its
demographic map to this day the moment
you get outside that ditch the roads
disappear unemployment shoots up you you
suddenly the poverty rate increases
dramatically lo and behold the Arab
Spring began in the most Europeanized
country in the Arab world but the but in
a town that lay outside that demarcation
ditch the fruit and vegetable vendor who
lit himself on fire and committed
suicide because of unemployment
lack of jobs and lack of opportunity did
so in a town way outside that ditch so
this is not a fatalistic or
deterministic interpretation of recent
events it just adds as I said earlier an
added layer of understanding to
everything else that we have how
geography can infer and infuse a deeper
understanding of things history starts
with the map but doesn't end with the
map it starts with the map in the long
term over 20-30 years you can forecast
the lot by geography in the short term
over the next 12 months
then it's more about personalities in
the interaction of personalities look at
Syria in 30 years I'll talk about
geography look in Syria in the next week
I'll talk about the interrelationship
between Obama and Putin and and the
Iranians and and Assad and others now
let's go beyond Tunisia a bit to give
you a deeper flavor of this what's
another a joel custer of civilization
that's been a state really since
antiquity with a road network or river
network Egypt of course in Egypt there
are many problems as we know there was
you know a toppling of the dictator
which was not a democratic uprising
regardless of what you read in the
newspapers it was the military using
demonstrations to get rid of a leader
who wanted to install his son in power a
son who would have liberalized the
economy and threatened the military's
hold on a lot of the parts of the
economy that had owned the military the
military ejected Mubarak the military
itself was overthrown in popular
demonstrations on the Muslim Brotherhood
came to power but then the military
reasserted itself and where were and
we're back with a military general and
control who's killed as many people in
the streets as Mubarak did
if not more Egypt like Tunisia is under
control it has an army that rules
it has bureaucracies it's chaos is about
politics it's about who rules and what
values they rule the state but the state
itself is not in question there is a
state there but if you look at what the
map shows between Tunisia and Libya
between Greater Carthage in the Nile
Valley what do you have you have just
the vague geographical expression that
in that in our age goes under the name
of Libya Libya is not a real state Libya
the northwestern Libya with the capital
of Tripoli is was historically triple
Latanya and all of the tribes were
oriented towards Tunis in Tunisia and
northeastern Libya Sarah Nayaka
including the city of Benghazi were
always oriented towards Alexandria and
the Nile Valley and Zahra nayaka and
Tripoli Tonya had very little to do with
each other historically the Italians did
not make a state and lo and behold
precisely because Libya isn't was not a
real state it required an extreme
suffocating form of authoritarianism to
hold it together under the name of
Qaddafi's rule if you look at a map of
North Africa from Morocco to Egypt you
will see and you look at where the Roman
settlements were you will see that they
clustered around what is today Morocco
what is today Tunisia and what is today
Egypt all the states that had relatively
moderate forms of dictatorship Egypt
Tunisia and the King of Morocco they may
not have been Democrats but they were
not on the level of authoritarianism as
Qaddafi or even of the Algerian generals
for much of Algeria's modern history
which also algeria like Libya
is another vague geographical expression
that's not a real country when we look
at dictatorships don't be stereotypical
there's all different kinds of
dictatorships from the most moderate and
liberal forms to the most liberal and
suffocating forms the king of morocco
the founder of modern to tunisia habib
bourguiba
the Nazarite pharaohs from nasser
himself to Mubarak in Egypt were all
relatively moderate dictators you could
say what you wanted as long as you
didn't actively work against the regime
you it didn't matter
you were okay but in places like Libya
or another vague geographical expression
which called itself a country but was
never a country by the name of Syria or
Iraq those places required more
suffocating forms of dictatorship
precisely because of the of geography
look at Syria but Syria is a name a
vague word for a place between the
Taurus Mountains in southern Turkey and
the nephew desert in northern Saudi
Arabia that includes the modern-day
countries of Syria Lebanon Jordan and
Israel in Syria you have the Shia
trending alle whites in the northwest
the Kurds in the Northeast the Sunni
Arabs in this in the Central Corridor
and the Druze in the south they're all
regionally based loyalty is to death
Nyssa T in sectarian identity not to a
state and the state was held together
under the most brutal means for 30 years
under Hafez al-assad and Hafez al-assad
was the Brezhnev Chernenko of the Middle
East he held together a place but kept
his people as subjects and never
developed citizenship and as a result
they never formed the state
and their identity was restricted to
their groups and one his son took power
and ran into trouble eleven years later
the state identity crumbled and you have
basically a morass of groups fighting
each other
why was Saddam Hussein so brutal when I
was in Iraq in quite a few times in the
1980s reporting on the iran-iraq war uh
what impressed me was how unlike any
other Arab country Iraq was it was so
much more brutal so much more sterile it
were going from Saddam's Iraq to Hafez
al-assad Syria was like coming up for
liberal humanists there that's how much
worse Iraq was than Syria why because
you had Kurds in the mountains in the
north
you had Sunnis in the center and you had
very tribal eyes she is in the south
because the the three groups were so
suspicious of each other it required an
extreme form of dictatorship to hold
them together so that geography
necessitated a form of dictatorship that
was far more extreme than Egypt where
geography led to a natural coherent
country the Nile Valley Yemen is another
age-old cluster of civilization except
when you go to Yemen you see the most
beautiful mountains on earth but because
it's such an extremely mountainous
landscape instead of one ancient culture
you had five or six you had Sabian's
Hemi Rocky's Hydra mootisse and others
and that's why on a good day the
president of Yemen Ali Abdullah Saleh up
until 2011 controlled maybe 50 percent
of the country and the people who
succeeded him even less again
geography rules to a great extent in in
and even to you know just to divert a
minute look at the United States
we're infused with ideas you know the
Jews Catholics Mexicans Muslims Hindus
who all become US citizens are all
honorary Protestants because they all
adopt the Protestant creed that's all
true but on the other hand there are
some geographical features that made
America great America was the last
resource rich part of the temperate zone
to be settled at the time of the
European enlightenment America has more
miles of navigable inland waterways than
the rest of the world combined and
unlike Russia where the great rivers run
north to south and thus divide the
country the great river systems in the
United States specifically the Missouri
go in a diagonal fashion northwest to
southeast and the Ohio River system
civil similarly and therefore they unite
this great continent which by the way
has more natural resources than any
other place of its size on earth from
strategic minerals and metals to energy
and you know to abundant water so so
remember geography plays a role and
geography can even infuse a people's
moral character I've always believed and
have written that it's the very beauty
and just spectacular immensity of the
Colorado Plateau of the mountains of
Utah and Colorado itself that gave the
Pioneers the sense that there was
something special about America and that
therefore they had a special destiny
different from other countries the
landscape played a role in shaping
people's spiritual mentality back to the
world I'm running out of time quickly um
let me look at Europe just for a few
minutes you read the newspapers about
Europe and your eyes blur it's all
economic the European Union debt they're
saddled in debt
Germans don't want to retire at 70 so
Greeks can retire at 55 the Northern
Europeans think the southern Europeans
are an inefficient and lazy and all
what's going on here it's more than
economics it's geography - if you look
at the it all the great treaty towns of
the European Union The Hague Maastricht
Strasbourg the others you will find that
Leiden they all they cohere perfectly
with Charlemagne's 9th century Empire
that the heartland of the European Union
the richest part of Europe economically
is Charlemagne's old Empire why is that
because that's the Europe united by a
river system with rich deep soils that
nevertheless have an opening to the
Atlantic and it an end to the Baltic Sea
but at the same time because of a screen
of islands in Holland haven't have an
immensity of protected harbours at
natural harbours at the same time so
that it's natural that Europe developed
with the this the economic and political
strength would be in the northwest of
Europe it's also natural that the
poorest most economically troubled part
of Europe would be the extreme southeast
and Greece which historically is a child
of Byzantine and Turkish despotism
because of geography that when we look
at Europe we're really seeing the
different economic and development
patterns of the Prussian Empire the
Habsburg Empire the Byzantine Empire the
Turkish Empire southern Mediterranean
Europe and they all developed along
different patterns economically which
led to different political patterns so
it would serve it was a very ambitious
idea to put all of these people under
one currency and not only one currency
but one currency where
without one political system yeah in
order to make the proper adjustments
through a central bank to fix things so
that Europe is reading in a very subtle
way more or less according to the two
age-old Imperial patterns if when the
day the Berlin Wall fell if you looked
at a map and you had to make a guess how
would the former Warsaw Pact countries
do you could have predicted on the map
how they would do at least for the next
20 years you would say Poland in the
Baltic States in the north would do the
best hairs to the Prussian tradition
hungry and check what was then
Czechoslovakia would do second-best hair
to the hacked Habsburg crown land
tradition and the most troubled places
would be in the Balkans which were here
too - a much weaker economic development
pattern first under the Byzantine Empire
until the mid 15th century and then the
Ottoman Turkish Empire and and that
wasn't just true of Yugoslavia which is
we know erupted into war but of near
anarchy and periodic cases of Anarchy in
Albania and Bulgaria and very weak
extremely corrupt slow growth economy
like Romania so the map teaches a lot
let me go beyond Europe to Russia for a
minute
Russia exists almost completely north of
50 degrees north latitude
that's cold now Canada is more or less
similar but everyone in Canada lives
along the US border essentially Canada
is like Chile laid on its side you know
that's what it is Canada is a
demographic extension of the United
States 300 million plus Americans live
in America and extra 33 million live
just north of the border but Russia's
different Russia's great population
zones Moscow st. Petersburg
far north of that 50 degrees north
latitude in fact the only place is south
of the caucuses which is Russia's
tropical area even though it's only
around Maine or so in terms of latitude
and in the extreme far east around Vlad
of austat because of the moderating
influence of the Western Pacific and
where it dips down it's a bit warmer as
well all right
that harshed that extreme cold led to a
certain communalism it led to a belief
it led to you know extreme and that
communalism led to an extreme religious
intensity it was said that um if you
wanted to understand Stalinism forget
marxist theory just look at the russian
orthodox church which was all about
totality and you know about totalism
total belief everything and stuck
remember Stalin was a seminary student
in Georgia he studied for the Orthodox
priesthood and his and his rhetoric very
much came out of that tradition Russian
communism is impossible to understand
without at least some reference to the
environment and to the geography now the
most important things about Russia is
Russia is a land Empire and land empires
are notoriously insecure especially if
you have a land empire that has no
mountains as natural or rivers as
natural borders Russia hasn't just been
invaded by Napoleon and Hitler but by
the Swedes the Lithuanians and the poles
too
so a lot amir putin rather than being
this evil demon that the media makes him
out to be is just a normal russian
autocrat who who looks at europe and
says i need a buffer zone the warsaw
pact may be dead okay
and I'm not gonna resurrect it because
that's what killed the Soviet Union
having to support those infernal
countries like Poland and
and others but I need a soft traditional
zone of influence in Central and Eastern
Europe in order to guard about against
future invasion likes because I'm in
incessantly insecure about Europe
because I'm a loyal Russian and I know
my history and therefore I'm gonna buy
up rail lines infrastructure banks I'm
gonna subvert these countries through
intelligence operations I'm not gonna
use my army but I'm gonna use everything
else to undermine every country from the
Baltics to the Balkans
I need a buffer zone in the Caucasus to
pretty you know to protect me against
its Islamic anarchy and fundament and
fundamentalism and I need to compete
with the Chinese in Central Asia because
it was a long border in the Far East
between Russia and China that led to the
sino-soviet split in the first place
where you had a million men under arms
and it was that that geography that
provided Nixon and Kissinger with the
opportunity in the first place to
triangulate China against the Soviet
Union because of China's fear of the
Soviet Union because of a long
unprotected border so Russia has no
mountains to protect it its rivers go in
the wrong direction
the rivers further decide the Far East
from Central from Siberia and Central
Siberia from Western Siberia and then
yet the Ural Urals which separate
Western Siberia from European Russia 11
time zones yet less people than
Bangladesh
if you ruled Russia you would be very
insecure and you would always be looking
for opportunities to undermine the West
on wherever you could even if you were a
democratically elected ruler let's move
on let's look at China China is south of
50 degrees north latitude
China's like the United States the
coldest part Manchuria Harbin is the
latitude of Maine the warmest part
Hainan Island in the South China Sea is
the lat
to to the Florida Keys and you have
everywhere in between and you had the
canal built in the 6th century between
the Yangtze and the Yellow River which
for China was like the Transcontinental
Railroad uniting the country so China's
in there in the perfect latitudes it's
opened up to the central asia with its
strategic minerals and metals it has a
it has a massive population of 1.3
billion people in the Russian Far East
you have 7 million going down to 4.5
million because of the demographic
crisis you have China pushing into
Central Asia building roads rail lines
pipelines for natural gas and oil you
have China proposing a
divide-and-conquer strategy versus the
economies of Southeast Asia China is
bigger on the map than it looks but
China is also much smaller and
claustrophobic because if you're an
ethnic Han Chinese you look to your
northern Borderlands and you have inner
Mongolians you look to your western
Borderlands and you have ethnic Uighur
Turkic Muslims and you look to your
southwestern Borderlands and you have
Tibetans and they all hate you and they
all live on the upland plateaus that's
where all the water sources are that's
where all the energy and minerals are so
you're just a small Han cradle core of
an island in Central and coastal China
and you know that the Americans lecture
you about human freedom and democracy
but you know better if you're the
Politburo of China you know little
democracy is going to lead to more and
more ethnic disturbances throughout
China
so you listen politely to your American
interlocutors and then ignore them
afterwards because China like Russia in
a way in a smaller way is a prison of
Nations and the minute that prison opens
up you have you know you have the
prospect of a greater Tibet which India
can use against China and and
and on and on let me talk about Iran for
a moment Iran's interesting I talked
about artificial countries in the Middle
East Libya Syria Algeria Iraq I talked
about Yemen is partially artificial not
wholly artificial there's nothing
artificial about Iran Iran's a real
state in fact as as Syria and Iraq
crumble and Lebanon and Jordan are under
stress the only two vibrant States
between the eastern edge of the
Mediterranean and the Central Asian
plateau is a Jewish state and a Persian
State keep that in mind
there is nothing artificial about Iran
Persia was the first great superpower in
antiquity if you look at the maps of the
various Persian empires the Medes the
Parthian 's the Achaemenids the
sassanids the cod jars and others what
you find is it roughly approximates the
area of Iranian influence today Lebanon
Syria certainly Iraq Western and Central
Afghanistan Iran has a terrorist network
of sort Empire of sorts from the
Mediterranean to central Afghanistan you
raw version historico Lee has had very
close relations with the Jews Persia
historically has had very bad relations
with the Arabs Persia historically will
be around for decades and decades to
come because I said it's a real state I
cannot promise you that Saudi Arabia
will exist for decades and decades to
come because Saudi Arabia is artificial
though I never got to talk about it
Saudi Arabia is not contiguous not
synonymous with the Irate trapezoidal
Arabian Peninsula in the way that Iran
is synonymous with the Iranian plateau
with the with the Iranian Plateau so it
wouldn't surprise me at all if ten years
from now the United States had closer
relations with Iran then it has today
with Turkey or Saudi Arabia and I infer
this from geography I infer that there's
a lot that the u.s. and Iran have to
talk to each other about they can each
do each other a lot of good in a naked
strategic fashion the the worst
nightmare of the Saudis in Riyadh the
absolute worst which infuses so many of
their conspiracy theories is that the US
will have a rapprochement with Iran
that's what really scare that's the
Saudi nightmare that Saudi Arabia has
led Wendling underground freshwater
sources that it has 40% male youth
unemployment that the royal family inner
circle is spreading from about 20 to
several hundred as as the as as as the
sons of the favored wife of eben souds
Susu dare died off and and you know just
con juries of grandchildren emerge
fighting for the spoils and the power
structure is split up and meanwhile the
Iranians and the Americans find they
have a lot to discuss around the table
and if they can get by this nuclear
issue III think you're gonna see a very
very different middle east let me let me
close with the Western Hemisphere let me
talk a little bit about the Western
Hemisphere and back to China for a
second China is push is projecting power
out into the South China Sea it's and
that's you know naval air and ballistic
missile power into the South China Sea
it's making countries like the
Philippines and Malaysia Indonesia
Singapore very nervous one thing I can
you American hard military power may not
be very popular in Europe but one place
where it's really popular is Asia the
Asians love American aircraft carriers
and fighter jets because that's what
helps them balance against China on it
China's pushing to the South China Sea
has made Vietnam America's new and best
de facto ally in Asia the Vietnamese
don't love us they love themselves and
they need us to balance against China
because as the Vietnamese tell me we
fought one war against the United States
we fought about 35 against China you
know over the course of the millennia
and by the way in that one war we
defeated you so we have no access to
grind chips on our shoulder or grudges
to bear about you we can meet you
psychologically as equals and therefore
we're in no way intimidated by your
power we need the vietnamese at this
moment are dredging and refurbishing Cam
Ranh Bay Naval Station in order to
invite in more US warships they want US
warships on the Vietnamese Coast this is
all because of Chinese power and now
back to the New World
what is the South China Sea to China
it's what the greater Caribbean was to
the United States in if you were a
foreign policy of fish annatto in the
19th century and early 20th and you were
very ambitious what area the world would
you become a specialist in the Caribbean
the Caribbean now is just for
holidaymakers but it wasn't always the
case it was by coming to dominate the
greater Caribbean meaning the Gulf of
Mexico and the Caribbean Sea that the
United States came to dominate the new
world because the greater Caribbean was
what's called the American Mediterranean
it basically not Yorktown to
yorktown to the Gianna's that was called
in terms of British colonial British
colonial history the the new the Western
Hemisphere is not geographically divided
between North American South America
it's divided between that area north of
the Amazonian jungle and south of the
Amazonian jungle because the Caribbean
is a connector not a divider whereas the
Amazon is a real impenetrable divider at
least until very very recently if you
look at a demographic map of Venezuela
Colombia the Guiana as you say oh
they're all in South America but you
look at where the people in those
countries actually live it's all along
the Caribbean coast their Caribbean
countries and by coming to dominate in a
naval sense a large measure due to Teddy
Roosevelt and other presidents America
got dominance of the whole Western
Hemisphere north of the Amazonian
jungles and south of the Amazonian
jungles all you had was the Southern
Cone which didn't come into economic
prominence until the last few decades
really
so the Caribbean was the secret sauce
that allowed America to gain control of
the Western Hemisphere and once it
gained control of the Western Hemisphere
it became a true hemispheric hegemon and
as a hemispheric hegemon it had power to
spare to affect the balance of power in
the eastern hemisphere and that is the
story of the 20th century America
affecting the balance of power and world
war one world war two the Cold War all
because of the Caribbean it all started
with the Caribbean and this is what the
Chinese want for the South China Sea the
control of the South China Sea allows
them allows them an opening to the
Indian Ocean as a major air and naval
power in the western Pacific China is a
great region
power as a great air and naval power in
the Indian Ocean and the Pacific it's a
great global power so again this is
where geography infuses us let me just
end with this we think that because of
computers electronic communications jet
travel that geography is being negated
geography is not being negated it's just
becoming more claustrophobic every place
matters now and interacts with every
other place to a degree that it didn't
in previous centuries we used to be able
to say Oh South America doesn't matter
Africa's of secondary importance not
anymore I didn't even talk about Africa
but maybe in the questions and answers I
could get into it but every place
interrelates it's like my watch fight
it's small but if I take it apart it's
gets very complex gears within gears
within gears and a relief map of the
earth is incredibly complex and yet it
in teaches teaches us more and more
about this increasingly shrinking world
we live in
thank you very much for your time and
now I'll take questions
you